>> Tucker: IT HASN'T BEEN A GOOD
THEY DON'T THINK ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE WORTH CLOSING THE
GOVERNMENT FOR.
ROBERT MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION
MUDDLES AHEAD.
MORE AND MORE EVIDENCE SUGGESTED
THAT THE FBI IS TOO
IDEALOGICALLY COMPROMISED TO
REACH TRUSTWORTHY CONCLUSIONS.
ARE WE REACHING THE RIGHT
BRIT HUME IS HERE WITH US TO ADD
MORE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU WILL.
THAT'S IMPLIED.
BAKED IN THE CAKE.
I WAS SHOCKED BY THIS SCHUMER
STORY THIS WEEK.
NUMBERS AS POLITICIANS OUGHT TO.
YET THEY WENT WAY OUT ON A LIMB,
>> I THINK, TUCKER, MY GUESS IS
THAT SCHUMER PROBABLY DIDN'T
THINK THIS WAS A GOOD IDEA.
PROBABLY RESISTED IT.
BUT THERE'S A STRENGTH OF THE
LEFT BRANCH OF HIS CAUCUS AS
SUCH THAT REMINDED ME IN THE END
VERY MUCH OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
2013 WITH TED CRUZ AND THE GROUP
OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS THAT WERE
IN SUFFICIENT NUMBERS THAT THEY
FORCED JOHN BOEHNER THAT WAS
RELUCTANT, THE THEN SPEAKER, TO
LET THEM GO FORWARD WITH THE
STRATEGY TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOWN TO LEVER PRESIDENT OBAMA TO
UNDOING A BIG PIECE OF
OBAMACARE.
IT FAILED UTTERLY.
THE MEASURES WENT NOWHERE IN THE
SENATE.
THE GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN.
THE PUBLIC DID NOT LIKE IT AND
THE HISTORY OF THE PUBLIC'S
IN THE END, THEY HAD TO BACK
I DON'T THINK THE LEADER LIKED
IN THE END, THEY GOT THEIR BUTTS
HANDED TO THEM AND HAD TO BACK
DOWN BECAUSE IT DIDN'T GO OVER
WELL.
A HAND OF THEM VOTED NO ON THE
FIRST GO ROUND LAST WEEK.
LEAST THAT THEY WERE LOSING AND
IT WAS HURTING -- COULD HURT
THEM BACK HOME.
SO THEY CAVED IN AND SCHUMER AND
THE FILIBUSTERING DEMOCRATS GOT
PRACTICALLY NOTHING.
>> Tucker: IT'S JUST REMARKABLE.
REPUBLICANS SEEM OUT OF TOUCH
WITH PUBLIC SENTIMENT, TOO.
THE NEW HARVARD POLL ASKED
PEOPLE DO YOU THINK WE NEED LESS
OR MORE IMMIGRATION.
THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS THAT
WANT MORE PEOPLE TO COME FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES, 12% WANT
MORE.
I WONDER WHY THEY'RE NOT AWARE
OF THAT?
NONE OF THEM SEEM AWARE OF THAT.
>> WELL, DEPENDS ON HOW YOU --
WHICH PIECE OF THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
THE IDENTIFY THAT WE WANT MORE
IMMIGRANT THAN WE'RE GETTING IS
NOT POPULAR.
BUT YOU SAY THE DACA PIECE OF
WAS THAT ALEXA.
I MANAGED TO WAKE ALEXA UP.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU SAYING AMAZON
IS MONITORING THIS CONVERSATION?
>> YEAH.
AMAZON.
I ASK HER ALL THE TIME, ALEXA,
ARE YOU SPYING ON ME?
LISTEN.
SHE DIDN'T ANSWER.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
ANYWAY, YOU LOOK AT DACA.
THIS IS A SUBSET OF THE
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY THAT CAME HERE AS WE
ALL HEARD SAID THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN WHEN THEY WERE
YOUNG, WHEN THEY WERE MINORS.
SOME SYMPATHY.
TO SEND THEM BACK TO SOMEPLACE
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN SEEMS
UNFAIR AND MOST AMERICANS --
SUPPORT FOR THAT.
AND THEN THERE'S THE QUESTION OF
WHAT YOU DO ABOUT THE ILLEGALS
ALREADY HERE.
THEIR PRESENCE HERE IS NOT
POPULAR AS YOU HAVE SUGGESTED.
BUT THEN THE QUESTION COMES IS
IT PRACTICAL TO ROUND THEM UP
AND SEND THEM HOME.
THAT'S A BRIDGE TOO FAR.
SO ONCE YOU GET PASSED THE IDEA
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE GENERAL IDEA
THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT MORE
IMMIGRATION AND THEY CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, IT GETS
COMPLICATED.
FROM HIS POINT OF VIEW IN
WANTING A SERIES OF BORDER
SECURITY MEASURES TO GO WITH ANY
DEPORTED.
SO THAT'S SORT OF WHERE WE ARE
IN THIS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE ANOTHER
NEGOTIATION COMING UP SOON AND
WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH THE DEMOCRATS
ARE WILLING TO GIVE IN ORDER TO
GET THE DACA REPEAL UNDONE.
>> Tucker: I'M LOOKING FORWARD